foreign
hey Angela welcome to the show
hey how are you doing we are doing well
how can we help
um first I want to say uh do you guys
remember the icky list that you guys had
done about um people consolidating the
deodorant stubbed into one yeah that was
us yesterday
yeah
that's that's totally me I listen to you
guys
at work I don't know what you're talking
about you don't put the hair in the
pillow though right like cute oh God no
no we were talking about weird Google
hacks me and George oh my gosh so how
long did it take you how long did it
take you to melt down all your deodorant
butts into one stick it only it really
only takes like two minutes
it's like 15 seconds in the microwave
and you just pour them into an empty
tube and it's so easy does it work just
does it I don't know
it is for me because I have been so
ghetto poor for the last three years
that um four or six dollars on a new
tube of um deodorant is gas money for
one day to work and that is true high
value for me okay you know what good for
you and if it only takes two minutes
like why not that's awesome I imagined
it would take longer kind of like
digging digging out all the videos
like if you've ever microwaved um icing
in a microwave it's it takes just that
long like 15 seconds it even has that
same consistency to it okay it's a good
April Fool's joke right there
all right
we're doing inside thank you Angela
thank you Angela so what's going on in
your life how can we help
um
okay so what I've got going on is like a
family struggle when it comes to money
so
um I've taken like a like a 15 years the
battery life in my family because they
have a tendency to borrow money and not
pay it back and
um my brother on the other hand and he's
he's doing really good in life like he's
worth over to two million dollars
and so when my parents need something
um he will call me and say you need to
pay half of those and I I just simply
don't have the funds I'm melting
deodorant to get by and
um so for me to come up with like 500 to
help fix something like a plumbing or a
septic system I just don't have that and
um there's like quite a bit of um
building tactics that are used on me
when I tell them I'll do what I can
because I used to just help and suffer
the consequence to my financial budget
and
um I've been making such big strides
this evening guys
I burn out and I'm just hurt by their
inconsiderateness towards me yeah yeah
you said I don't know if I heard this
correctly but did you say you took a
15-year sabbatical from the family
I did so there's there's some there's
some stuff there right right
um yeah I definitely grew up with a good
bit of them verbal abuse and physical
abuse and
my brother was
um the favorite Child and he definitely
was not treated the same
and um I was born with
um I don't need disorders and then
um
muscular apathy
yeah and then I was always kind of seen
them as the suburbance
yeah so you you took this 15 years and
then you all came back together and and
your parents your brother's expecting
you to pay for your parents
needs is that correct like on their
house right do your parents right do
they not have money do they not have
income
they
um they didn't manage their money
properly
um and so I want to just release you
that they were working okay this is not
your responsibility
we can honor our parents but this is not
your responsibility and the fact that
your brother
is using bullying tactics against you
and then all the things that you were
just listing out of your childhood
growing up and then taking and then
having some boundaries around them in
the recent years I think there needs to
be another really hard conversation but
you need to protect yourself I mean
there's a level here that is not not
only that it's not fair for you it's
just wrong it's wrong the way that
they're treating you and again even if
you had the money
right even if you had it it's still your
money that you get to decide and if you
felt like yeah this is something I want
to be generous with with mom and dad
like I then I get to decide that as
Angela I'm not going to be forced into a
situation of what I don't need to do so
I don't know if it's a conversation that
you need to have with your brother and
draw a really hard boundary and just say
I'm not giving any more money
whether I have it or not I'm deciding
right now that I I don't like the way
this has been going down and so I'm
sorry but I I'm drawing that and he may
get all
angry and pissed and and I don't and who
knows what he'll say right I'm like I I
don't I don't know the situation
um but I think John deloney Dr John
deloney would say there that that you
need to protect yourself in a boundary
allows you to do that and yeah there's a
space between the 15-year Gap where it's
like you don't talk at all it's cold
turkey and the bullying and bad feelings
that you felt growing up and you know
they don't get to drag you into that as
an adult you're an adult now and I know
it's hard when you have childhood trauma
to put up boundaries like that's hard
because you're triggered whenever you
know they say those things it's like
you're all of a sudden you're 12 years
old again and you're feeling those
emotions but like Rachel said you are
because that right yeah you are released
from that and and even though it may
feel mean even though when you put the
boundary up they are probably not gonna
like it they may even say some mean
things but that's okay that that's and
that's why you put up the boundaries
because of that kind of people yeah yeah
they are they want to have every
conversation via text because they're
the kind of people that screenshot
things and post them on Facebook and
crop it to spend their life in oh yeah
no that's toxic yeah no light as they
can yeah I'm out it's it's there's even
a chance that this boundary needs to be
again where there's not a lot of contact
very often like that is okay that's
that's toxic and I'm sorry you're going
through that
um we're gonna gift you a copy of own
your past change your future by Dr John
deloney because I think there's going to
be a lot of healing for you in this
um in this next few years I think it's
going to take some time for you to
process a lot of that trauma and to kind
of work through it because man family
stuff can be so hard and especially when
they're still behaving that way it'd be
different if they had gone through their
own healing journey and weren't
counseling and we're trying to work and
repair things but it does not sound like
they are willing to change want to
change and if anything they're trying to
drag you right back in yes so I hope
Angela that you hear us just say you are
released from responsibility I think
financially and even relationally to a
point
um that there needs to be relational
boundaries and financial boundaries
really strong ones drawn so again um
yeah Jenna's gonna pick up and and read
Dr John Delaney's book because it is
really helpful to acknowledge what has
happened I mean it's it is all about
owning your past and we all have stories
of this right some the level of trauma
the stories look different
um but man there there's a lot there to
unpack for you Angela and so even get
with a good therapist and counselor if
you haven't yet because we everyone I
would recommend that to everybody
sitting down and unpacking your story
because it is so helpful to engage who
you are today and then help give you the
confidence
to make decisions for what's best for
you Angela in your life and in your
money so I hope I hope you do that so
again General pick up and you can get a
copy of that but well that's a huge part
of changing your future too is it's like
it's not like the past just stays in a
perfect box like you're still dealing
with these people in real time so it's
not like you can just you know cut it
off and that's it like it's like you
have to figure out new systems new
boundaries new ways to move forward
that's going to protect you and help you
have a full life because it's like when
you're constantly feeling that
negativity when those people are
constantly trying to drag you back into
your past it's like that can really hurt
you moving forward so you know feel the
freedom to set those boundaries and own
your future that's right absolutely
thanks Angela for the call